[Music]
this morning on the dish the James Beard
Award winner for Best Chef northeast
growing up in New Jersey Karen hakuna
what's never planned on being in the
restaurant industry
it wasn't until her 20s that she tried
her hand in the kitchen and soon dreamed
of opening her own restaurant after
culinary school a year in Italy and work
at top Boston area restaurants
she became executive chef at Boston's
acclaimed Myers & Chang that's where she
created Asian style dishes that won her
the Beard Award and other big honors now
she's moved on to that dream of opening
her own venue Fox and the knife with an
Italian inspired menu in a warm wine bar
setting debuts in Boston's South End
early this year we spoke with her
recently chef Karen Nakata whit's
welcome to the dish thank you so much
that is so cool I have to admit I've
been somewhat mesmerized by this
beautiful cocktail but tell her what's
on the rest of it
so cocktail first the Aperol spritz yes
laughs I got prosper it's one of my
favorite hosts Italy perfect yeah cheers
cheers Cheers
Oh dead silence so today we have a
couple different recipes pork has a lot
breaded pork Milanese a with Honey Crisp
apples and then we have some dishes from
the Myers & Chang at home cookbook that
came out last year so sweet-and-sour
Brussels sprouts Brussels sprouts
agrodolce long beans Amandine smashed
fingerling potatoes with chili jam and
cilantro and a little bit of chocolate
tofu mousse that's what I was right with
first eat dessert first that's what
Joanne Chang always says so I have to
say you you started on this endeavor
late in life
I did most chefs start as children yeah
how did how did you come to Italy you
know I sort of came to the kitchen from
from the front door actually from the
other way around I've worked in
restaurants since I was 17 years old I
was a waitress in a diner in New Jersey
I mean that's really my first my first
restaurant job that's where it all
started and and I
love hospitality I love restaurants in
general I love that we come together and
it feels special when you go out to eat
and you know when I was a kid we didn't
we didn't have a ton of money so if you
if you went out to eat it was a it was a
big deal it's a special occasion and I
love that feeling you talked a little
bit about it but what is it about
cooking that you love so much what is it
that just drew you there I mean I think
it's just you know this exactly this
right making food for somebody sitting
down sharing food and what comes with
the spirit of sitting down together and
and eating food together and making
think something for somebody it's a
little bit of like love on a plate right
your first your first kitchen job ended
up being a kind of a trial by a fire
oh my gosh absolutely when the chef got
violently ill that is correct
it was my I mean it was my first day my
first day and my first job as a line
cook there was a very small restaurant
there were only 10 it's actually called
10 tables only 10 tables and the owner
looked at me and said if I don't take
any walk-ins do you think you could cook
for the reservations that were coming in
she said I'll make you know I'll make
the salads can you work the stove and I
in my head I thought I can't absolutely
I cannot do this I have no idea what the
celery's well I've never worked the line
before I have no idea what I'm doing
but you know I said I like you I can try
we got through it we fed people I'm not
sure how well we fed them if anyone you
know is watching this that was there
that night thank you thank you but yeah
that was that was kind of it and you
know as challenging it was that was kind
of like it was also like the moment
where I was like oh this I guess is the
hem what has this been like getting
ready to open your own place it's really
exciting it's of course stressful I mean
that's the reality of it but it's really
exciting and it's you know not to sound
cheesy but it's it's kind of a dream
come true when I found this space I knew
this is the restaurant that I wanted to
to put there I just felt it's a
neighborhood spot it's on this great
corner in South Boston and I think it
just calls for you know someplace that
you know for lack of a better like
someplace everybody knows your name and
warm and well
coming and for me living in Italy for a
year
that's the spirit of Italian dining
right it's the coming together it's
upper TiVo it's you know the most
important thing next to what's for
dinner is what's for lunch and and that
was that's what this this space said to
me so yeah that's exciting I love it
well we want to congratulate now but if
there is anyone past or present oh gosh
share this meal with who would it be
that's a just so many people I just
actually I just saw Lucinda Williams in
concert choice oh my gosh and I am she's
just one of my favorite artists ever and
if she would play for me I would
absolutely for being here for signing
today to see she did a job for more on
Karen and the dish add to our website at
cBS This Morning Calm